♪ ♪
>> Sean: RAPPER T.I. TWEETED
OUT WHAT IS A DESPICABLE,
DISGUSTING VILE VIDEO ATTACKING
THE FIRST LADY.
WERE NOT GOING TO SHOW A LOT BUT
HERE'S A PART OF IT.
♪ ♪
THE LEFT'S NEVER ENDING AND
RECENT VILE SMEARS AGAINST THE
FIRST LADY DIDN'T STOP THERE.
LAST FRIDAY, ONE OF THE COHOSTS
OF THE VIEW SUGGESTED THE
FIRST LADY MAY HAVE BEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S MISTRESS.
THESE ARE VILE ATTACKS, WATCH
THE SPIRIT OF >> IS IT POSSIBLE
THAT SHE'S NOT CONCERNED WITH
HIS MISTRESSES BECAUSE SHE WAS
ONE OF THEM?
IS THAT POSSIBLE?
>> Sean: IT'S NO WONDER THE
FIRST LADY TOLD ABC SHE WAS ONE
OF THE MOST BULLIED PEOPLE
BECAUSE IT'S TRUE.
HERE WITH REACTION,
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
DAUGHTER-IN-LAW BORROWED FROM.
I KNOW MELANIA I'VE HAD A CHANCE
TO MEET HER.
ENGLISH IS HER FIFTH LANGUAGE,
AMAZING BACKGROUND, LIFE,
CAREER, YOU SAW THE INCREDIBLE
TRIP SHE JUST TOOK.
THE DIGNITY, THE CLASS SHE HAS.
IF YOU'RE NOT A DEMOCRAT, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE SILENT.
THEY ONLY WANT TO GO AFTER JUDGE
KAVANAUGH FOR DEFENDANT STORMY
BUT NOT IVANKA WHEN THE C WORD
IS USED, NOT YOU WHEN YOU'RE
ATTACKED.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT HAPPENING
TO MICHELLE OBAMA EVER OR
HILLARY CLINTON EVEN.
>> THE SUPPOSED PARTY OF WOMEN
IS COMPLETELY SILENT HERE.
I'M WAITING FOR ANYONE TO SPEAK
UP AGAINST THIS ON THE DEMOCRATS
SIDE.
WE HAVE HEARD ABSOLUTE CRICKETS
FROM THEM.
IT'S DISGUSTING AND IT'S NOT
THAT SHOCKING ANYMORE BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS NO LOW TOO
LOW FOR THE LEFT, FOR THE MEDIA,
FOR HOLLYWOOD.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PRESIDENT
AND THE FIRST LADY AND THE
ENTIRE FIRST FAMILY, I DON'T
CARE WHAT SIDE OF THE POLITICAL
AISLE YOU'RE ON.
THE FIRST LADY OF THE
UNITED STATES DESERVES RESPECT.
THIS IS DISGUSTING AND IT SHOULD
BE CONDEMNED BY EVERYONE.
>> Sean: I DON'T HEAR ANY
CALLS FOR FBI INVESTIGATIONS OF
KEITH ELLISON LIKELY DID WITH
JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
THOSE ALLEGATIONS WERE SO
OVER-THE-TOP, IT WAS PATENTLY
ABSURD.
I DON'T SEE THEM EVER DEFENDING
MELANIA TRUMP EVER.
>> DOUBLE STANDARD ACROSS THE
BOARD.
YOU THINK ABOUT HOW DIFFERENTLY
IF THIS WERE OUR PREVIOUS
FIRST LADY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO YOU VOTED
FOR WHETHER OR NOT YOUR DEMOCRAT
OR REPUBLICAN, THIS IS
DISGUSTING AND IT ABSOLUTELY
SHOULD BE CONDEMNED BY EVERYONE.
>> Sean: I KNOW YOU'RE WORKING
ON "20/20" BUT AN INTERESTING
PHENOMENON IS HAPPENING.
WE HAVE THIS IMPORTANT ELECTION.
THINGS SEEM TO HAVE SHIFTED
DRAMATICALLY ESPECIALLY IN THE
SENATE RACES.
I WORRY MORE ABOUT THE HOUSE I
THINK PEOPLE PAY CLOSE ATTENTION
IF THEY VOTE FOR A CONGRESSMAN,
THEY VOTE FOR PELOSI.
DO YOU SEE REAL TROUBLE FOR
CLAIRE McCASKILL WHO'S BEEN
EXPOSED, DEAN HELLER IS DOING
BETTER IN NEVADA, KRISTEN CINEMA
IS COLLAPSING IN ARIZONA, HEIDI
HEITKAMP IS COLLAPSING.
JOE DONNELLY IS IN TROUBLE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO PEOPLE WITH
THESE HOUSE RACES WHO ARE MORE
CONCERNED TONIGHT?
>> THE ENTIRE MIDTERM ELECTION
IS SO IMPORTANT.
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE THE PRESIDENT
ON THE ROAD LIKE HE'S BEEN.
YOU JUST MENTIONED ALL OF THESE
RACES, THIS IS MAKING AN IMPACT
WITH PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WHO ARE VOTING IN THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
OFTEN TIMES THE MIDTERMS ARE NOT
AS EXCITING FOR PEOPLE TO GET
OUT AND VOTE IN.
PEOPLE STAY HOME, YOU CANNOT
STAY HOME ON NOVEMBER 6TH.
EARLY VOTING ON NORTH CAROLINA
STARTS TOMORROW.
I WAS THERE ALL DAY, CAMPAIGNING
WITH SOME GREAT CANDIDATES IN
NORTH CAROLINA.
YOU'VE GOT TO GET OUT AND VOTE
EARLY AND YOU'VE GOT TO VOTE FOR
REPUBLICANS.
>> Sean: IMPEACHMENT, ENDLESS
INVESTIGATION.
OPEN BORDERS BUT DON'T SAY IT,
KEEP OBAMACARE.
THAT'S THE WHOLE AGENDA.
>> AND SOCIALISM, OF COURSE.
IT'S CRAZY WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
ARE PROPOSING AND I HOPE
EVERYONE IS PAYING ATTENTION
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO KEEP THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE IN THE
MIDTERM.
>> Sean: THANK YOU FOR BEING